stop the show Gang let's talk about that
middle class famous store baby oh baby
coming up to the fourth quarter on that
down to the Finish Line only a few times
to see us again gang It's a Good Time
come on out and see the live show to mix
the stand-up comedy plus we played a
little late YG with the crowd it's a
great way to introduce new people to the
show so bring the squad with ya uh
Philadelphia sold out you snooze you
lose we got some tickets left for the
second show in Providence Rhode Island
in December and we got some a few
tickies left for our second show in
Boston in December get those hickies
let's party Gang This podcast is brought
to you by good friends over there to
establish titles with established titles
you can purchase as little as one square
foot of land and you can call yourself a
lord or a lady how about that
it's fun and it helps reserve the
Scottish Woodlands let's go I know uh
Guys established all those plants a tree
and works with global Charities support
Global reinforce station efforts in
every order so you're helping while you
become a landowner there you go title
packs give you at least one square foot
of dedicated land on a private estate in
Edison Scotland Run an official
certificate with a Crest boom I got it
in my hand baby to give it to you look
at you uh it makes an amazing last
minute gift uh established is running a
Black Friday sale right now plus if you
use the code garbage like this show you
get an additional 10 off your purchase
plus we win our beats we wet our beaks a
little bit the boys there you go I this
listen you want to be a landowner do you
rent like me you want to get your hands
on a part of the rock boom you got it
right there be a landowner throw it in
your dad's face told you never mounted
nothing but an established titles not me
personally but a guy I know go to
established titles.com garbage to get
your gifts now and help support the
channel do it welcome so another
exciting edition of are you garbage the
show where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan
and H Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast this is are you garbage it's
that little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find it at the
group to be classy back to just a mega
old piece of trash trash I'm your
hostage fully coming at you on a
beautiful day we're down here at
antuti's basement she got into those
Mountain Dew hard ciders pretty strong
yikes she'll be out for a couple of days
all right going night night my co-host
is coming at you from across the table
that's a swing and a mystery two up two
now for your kids keeping score at home
he is the CEO of Ru garbage is my best
pal in the whole wide world and I'll
tell you what I don't care how baldy is
I love them give it up for KJ Kevin
James Ryan thank you fat ass
that was just a cold form what's up gang
as always please make sure you rate
review subscribe over there all the
iTunes or the Spotify order whatever you
listen on and then obviously uh uh
YouTube we got full video available on
YouTube and those numbers are
cooking hundred thousand we can't thank
you enough gang we love you to death I
put in for the plaque you did it did or
under review
so those 70 000 Chinese Bots I bought
yikes guys and obviously the greatest
website of all time you can't choose
these numbers these are Ironclad
www.patreon.com are you garbage it's a
[ __ ] party oh man that's when a dead
raccoon hits the road you know what I'm
saying yeah good good time that's good
eating yes it is you ever have roadkill
what guys have a nice quick shout out to
our producer extraordinaire the magic
man makes us all look good works the
ones and twos crosses the t's dots the
eyes the apps
gang Tebow McMuffin Toby McMullen
everybody what's up dudes and I'm so
[ __ ] sorry my bad deleted it up we
had one in the can I was skinning in it
it was beautiful it was Steve Martin was
a guest I swear to God
Steve Martin I already Cable Guy Jeff
Foxworth is crazy yeah well what are you
gonna do we'll have him back next time
there in town guys we love you
uh this is a family episode this is the
best of the Business Circle in the
wagons this is it I don't need no other
bozos letting your hair down just us and
the bozos and the homies those famous
people
hanging out the guys the boys the gals
the whatever they then you'd rather hang
out with a dude in the same t-shirt and
drink in a warm Red Bull oh I'm sorry
was it not I knew I was crazy I just was
crazy you haven't complained yet about
something coming back from the store
sure I was shocked I didn't get pushback
until we press record and you got to
throw it away the fruit salad stunk
that's been in there since Tuesday well
you know and you're right about those
protein bars right about you complaining
yeah yeah you're right about the protein
bars they're no good for you they're
good that's good chewing though man yeah
so dude they're candy bars
in your pocket really is though man I
love that chew yeah the Power Bars were
my favorite when I was a kid my brother
he was like working out and stuff like
that at I don't know how he got it but
he got a box of them working out in the
80s or night was like a thing a lot of
cut off he didn't know yeah it was like
it was I'm working out yeah you know
what I mean it was like you had an
attitude for some reason you were
working out and you were pumping iron in
the 90s you were a bit of a dick
whatever Nautilus was they were doing it
him and his friends were all doing a
good not a decal Nautilus working out I
went in there once like nope hey where
the chicks is there a bar around here a
sausage fest in here uh but yeah he had
a box of Power Bars and man I would just
sneak in there
foreign
I thought there was a banana one
maybe that was runts
I can't remember I'm imagining your
brother is working out with the thing
with the handle with all the Springs
yeah that and the other thing that was
big in the 80s and 90s was the grip oh
forget it yeah don't get near that guy
if that guy is watching a basketball
court or something like that working at
the sports getting ready to open a jar
of pasta yeah yeah yeah got that got the
mega grip two of those going
yeah wild now he he had the straps for a
little while the wraps up for your hands
for the for the bench press he had that
I was all natural
guys al fresco over here I did have the
Hulkamania workout set when I was real
little
what's that racism and uh sun in or
something what's going on bleach now you
had a barbell yeah you had a two
dumbbells you had a jump rope a dumbass
daughter
shout out to Brooke by the way hey don't
be don't be throwing [ __ ] at Brooke I
used to tug my route to that show pack
of rubbers in there it was all right
oh it can't be popping kids on the road
a bag of coke
a couple Cycles a win straw you'll be
[ __ ] cooking patio Ultimate Warriors
dealer's number
that's what I'm talking about girl named
Tammy in Tampa shout out to Tammy I like
that I like that that's good I got a
little oh sorry I was gonna say I love
that 80s look that was my thing when I
was a kid because I was a kid I think
your thing is now if you had to describe
your aesthetic your style your Swagger I
would say gluten's up there I'm heavy
and gluten yeah I like I got it all in
gluten full in oh Deuces
um just had the cholesterol checked
uh-huh waiting to hear back
and get you up on a wreck
I'm not gonna know much so I get you up
on a lift there it's hard
Charlie's at lunch he'll be back in a
minute
at the 32-point inspection going yeah
you know how you do it check
um don't buy the air filter I don't need
another stress test or anything he said
the heart's looking good
so I got another 50 pounds I could put
on oh yeah okay guy took the governor
off so I can go full full 500.
yeah yeah good stuff what were you gonna
say I apologize I rudely cut you off
it's okay
um I had a little bit of an etiquette
not an etiquette thing
third gray areas that this show lives in
a little bit what to do in the moment
right
last night I went out to dinner uh with
my lady and we went down we went to a
restaurant that a friend of uh hers runs
runs yeah that could be a tricky
situation so uh and like I'm a very like
rule kind of got like I want to know
what I'm getting into and I [ __ ] up I
didn't bring cash because I had a
feeling the bill was going to be waived
a bit really babe I didn't know and you
still showed up empty I knew that was a
possibility when I was running late we
got out of it we got out of here late I
can't stop at an ATM cash it I wasn't
thinking I was trying to get there on
time but I needed a Snickers bar you'd
find one wouldn't you Milky Way man
myself are you really power bar banana
you believe that it's good stuff
um I might be making that up in my head
so uh
uh we get there I got I'm cashless
we get there it's me the lady and uh he
takes great care of us it's uh is he
waiting on you yeah it's a little bit of
a team what's he do he he's the manager
yeah he's running the show the general
manager just a floor manager that night
general manager I believe okay yeah yeah
okay um calling the shots my
understanding I mean everybody was going
to him right everybody was kissing a
ring okay you know what I mean kissing
the kissing the onion ring first if you
if you will
um
so my wife and his wife are friends they
live in the building okay right next
door they're friends
so my wife had gone in there before and
was like he gave us a pretty big
discount like she went in with uh her
friend or what I don't even know
whatever so I go all right cool I don't
know so I'm figuring something you know
what I mean take off a couple rounded
drinks or the [ __ ] appetizer he had
nine of them so we can we get like I
took it easy I'll have your second most
expensive one I want the first as well
but I will also take the second
and two buckets of beers
oh
um
so he does it if he he executed
everything relatively personally what
kind of joint what kind of food are we
talking uh I don't know Italian no they
had pastas uh burger like good bar food
like good bar like proper good bar food
okay it was one of those things where
he's like you want to do appetizers I go
yeah we were thinking I was looking
[ __ ] [ __ ] I was like I was
looking at this I was the first thing to
do is insult me oh he goes I got you so
like I was like all right let's see oh
really kind of so he brings out smaller
plates but of multiple things what are
we talking
uh talking some octopus grilled octopus
which I'm not an octopus guy this [ __ ]
would blow your dick I'm a huge octopus
guy I'm just not doing it anymore uh-huh
are they yeah why that documentary I
don't know they got through a hole the
guy who [ __ ] what are you doing I
just feel you know what else is smart
cows chickens turkeys gobble Cliff Cliff
Bars
but that is a pretty smart idea you
don't got a problem [ __ ] killing him
I'll eat squid all day they're the same
thing nah can't do it octopus anymore
but go ahead you do yourself you would
have done this octopus I'm telling you
really yeah well hell I mean if it was
on a table how about I want him we won't
go back then he was already murdered
famous people go to this place too oh
really yeah see anybody uh it's all my
reflection in the mirror now ah no he
said actors a bunch of actors and stuff
come in okay by Broadway so it's a real
small small joint too I understand yeah
yeah
um
so he comes he drops the apps apps are
good some spinach artichoke dips well
you know a couple of two three things
drinks are coming got the beers coming
they make me a cocktail as well uh
um get a beer and a cocktail I had a
beer uh and then they were talking about
this cocktail because can I say this I'm
listening this might be a symptom of
alcoholism but I don't mind
multiple drinks a cocktail and a beer
just having an idea I don't like backup
yeah no I don't like doing that I I pick
my lane and I stay in my Lane you on the
other hand are what we call in the
business a booze bag follow the road
yeah did you go out to dinner with us
guys let me go take a red wine an IPA I
do do that I do do that I'll take a
vodka dirty whatever I do do that like
when we were at galleys we started out
with an IPA at the bar State ipas you
stay at IPA he's a gentleman well if I
would have got to the table directly
when I walked in I would have ordered my
cocktail but I was hemmed up
that's life with you I'll make it next
time see if we get a little bit
different
treatments in Milwaukee or something
you're gonna do the wrong location we'll
walk into the through the kitchen
yeah
we're closing that night
no yeah I did a beer then then the dirty
martini
um glass of red wine dirty underwear
I brought those myself and then and then
an espresso Martini because we were
going out they're all over the road yeah
yeah all right watch out for this I just
you're the only guy I know that does
that huh maybe like I don't know I feel
like uh something you were when I go out
like my wife's family I feel we'll do
that you something to start they'll
change it up glass of wine with this
meal sure then like a [ __ ] you know
something something whatever right right
you are no European no I am not
um so
then we do everything everything's good
you want the dessert and now we got to
get out of there we're going to uh Kinky
Boots we're going to a show you got
friends on bro our other friends in in
Kinky Boots look at you she's a social
butterfly that one look at you not me no
no
I'd be under the bed if it's possible
with times that's right you brought a
sandwich I'm fine thank you
um
so now we're like running it's getting
kind of time we we gotta [ __ ]
skedaddle right and there's no like uh
I don't know how to ask
for I think asking for the check would
be like
over the you know I didn't I didn't know
how to Broach this subject this is what
I was like we gotta go yeah this free or
what yeah am I paying for this or can I
[ __ ] go yeah you need anything for
this what's the deal so you didn't this
is the question you're putting but
there's also good conversation but my
anxiety is running up like all right man
we got you know 20 minutes to get there
it's 12 minutes what like I'm like I'm
not everybody's hanging out having a
good time and I'm kippy's being crazy a
little cray-cray I gotta get out of here
I gotta get out of here we didn't need
to I mean yeah whatever so I always got
to get out of there no matter what
[ __ ] they're always coming I don't
know I don't know what the next thing is
but let's get out there let's get
outside figure it out get a heater get
my [ __ ] head on straight check my
[ __ ] six will you yeah I'm always
ready to go uh so uh we so I got oh [ __ ]
I think I like oh [ __ ] I gotta get out
of here right at 6 40 whatever
so then he goes uh I just I [ __ ] up I
should have had cash he goes uh this is
on me because it's all all clear
so in my head did you do that now don't
do that come on that's crazy uh just
give him a little pushback I don't even
think so really yeah okay I said are
these freeze walking with some [ __ ]
lemon slices and [ __ ] you put these in a
bag
grab one of the waitresses let's go
honey she's with me
that's bad you got to give a little push
back if you're asking no I think I have
Council uh no he's been inviting us for
a long I understand but he's been
inviting us for a long time I just I
think I might not oh really you didn't
have to thank I thank you I appreciate
but it's also like
we've been in that where it's like the
fake him and Hauling
just hey thank you you're doing a nice
gesture thank you I appreciate that but
now it's time for you to do your nice
job but now it's time for me to do my
nice gesture but so you ain't got it so
my wife go I'll be like octopus last
time my wife was there she's like oh he
charged us like half and then like we
tipped it well she gave a discount he
goes this is on me so but like doesn't
even present me a bill so I got nothing
so I got no like I'm flying Mega blind
here and I got no case let's say that
dinner was 150 bucks so he goes uh
do you want uh I go [ __ ] I was like I
don't have any cash on me he goes okay
so he charged me he goes if you want to
leave don't leave anything to me he's
like if you want to leave something to
the to the guys
of course you have to you know all right
all right Easy Does It Easy Does It but
do you think there's a world where I
think I don't know you're looking at
yourself in the mirror you're you're
eating octopus I don't know who you are
going to Kinky Boots
got friends it's crazy there you go so
he goes all right so we so I was like so
then he walks away and I'm like telling
my wife I'm like hey this is like the
Super Bowl for me to figure out like I
don't know what this is costing the
whole nine yards I just want to make
sure I do the right thing you know what
I mean
so she goes he gave us an itemized
breakdown and just did like a like a
discount like if it was like a hundred
bucks he charged us 90 or whatever you
know what I mean okay doesn't do that I
just get a bill for one dollar and nine
Cent he just charged like a dollar so I
could dip so I'm still flying them
what's 12 of uh
so
I don't know anything
right uh-huh I don't know I gotta figure
I probably think I had two beers and a
cocktail you had two beers in a cocktail
how many hours but the cocktail was on
them they were talking about I was like
oh that sounds cool and they're like I
won't make you one it was that it was
like you know because we're at the bar
okay
two beers
two bears I would assume the thing would
be on the cuff but throw it I mean it's
probably pretty throwing it in there now
how many appetizers they're a small
plate they were small they don't call
them they don't call them appetizers
they call them small plates they're
terrible two smaller plates two one
three we could do the math actually I
could pull up the menu we could do the
math you want to do that oh very good
well don't tell me because I I'm doing
it okay I'm doing it a little bit all
right so I'm gonna say the two small
plates for that each got an entree uh
yes what's the bird drinking one of her
mocktails she's doing a mocktail but
again it was more like hey do you have
something you can whip up for her
because we had a liaison but charge one
mocktail pull one mock they might not
have put those in
um I'm gonna say okay well what was the
entree was it was there meat involved uh
she did fish I did a Berg she did the
birds they're known for their burgers
it's like the Branzino whole fish or
filet fillet with sides
uh some sort of puree it looked like
came with it yeah on the plate on the
plate side separate no and then a
dessert what are we looking at uh
nothing for did nothing for dizzy you
said there was dessert said it came time
to dessert and that's when I was like I
gotta he's like you won't notice that
coffee espresso no no no espresso no
espresso I never do espresso what do you
but I'm a [ __ ] American God damn it
give me a cup of coffee you have an
espresso give me a Starbucks you have a
you have coffee whatever you gotta have
something you have a you have a you have
a after dinner cocktail doing espresso
you're only doing espresso with the
cloaks out if you ran out of coke are
you talking about
okay
do a little adding here 10 20 32
47 this is where I'm gonna get jammed up
carry the 12. what's 47 and 15 Toby
uh
of 63. 63.
63 68
98 98 and 25.
you're asking yeah what do you mean when
I point to you 123. okay all right you
got tax and title this is very hard
Feeling by the way but we'll get into it
okay I'm not good at math I'm only gonna
delete in episodes I got a number I got
a number I got a number of what the
meals should be and I also have a number
on the inside of what you should have
left okay so we'll see how you do uh
give me one second here might be pulling
your card here grab you by the year and
take you back to that restaurant
get you straightened out keep up with
that butcher box baby but your box put
your box who but your butcher box
butcher box gang we love them and if
it's if it's ever meat eating season it
is right now yeah a couple of birds
couple of hands couple of baking yeah
let's go gang everybody's looking for
Black Friday deals I'll tell you one
that'll knock your socks off butcher box
baby that's where you want to go where
are you gonna get top quality meat from
the grocery store no kick rocks and
they're gonna bang over ahead with the
price yeah butcher box we're talking
free range we'll talk a wild caught
we're talking grass-fed we're talking
grass spinach and the deals for Black
Friday through the roof yes guys I've
said it once I said it a bajillion times
I'm a butcher box man through and
through everybody else can kick rocks
yeah they got bacon coming out my ass I
got [ __ ] ground beef coming out my
ears I got rib eyes I got T-Bones too
many if you catching my drift uh guys
this Black Friday butcher box is
offering our listeners their best steak
deals get two this is one ounce rib eyes
free three in every box for a whole year
what when you one of these guys made a
meme plus an additional 10 off sign up
today at butcherbox.com ayg use code ayg
that's free very buys for a year plus
ten dollars off watch at butcherbox.com
ayg code ayg do it yeah the show is
sponsored by betterhelp gang you got
things in your life that you don't know
what to do with are you all Screwballs
because I am T-Bone just signed up it's
all over the map over here you whack a
dude like me and Kippy now the truth is
is that life doesn't come with the
instruction manual no yeah I can't
forbid our parents didn't know yeah I
can't open my glove box I don't know
what's going on but gang it'd be nice if
it did and let me tell you something if
you got something that's eating away at
you talk to somebody about it and you
can do that with better help it's fast
it's easy and you can do it from the
privacy of your own home yeah guys uh I
have like I've always said to uh talk
therapy has helped a lot that's nuts hey
what are you talking about uh I've
recently signed back up for better help
it's helped me out immensely yeah
I'm crazy someone help me it's like this
is what I'm feeling this is what I'm
thinking I need help with you know if
you're in a jam whatever it's it's easy
peasy it's very convenient I highly
suggest it as the world's largest
therapy service better help us match
three million people with professionally
licensed and vetted therapists available
100 online plus it's affordable just
fill out a brief questionnaire to match
with your therapist if things aren't
clicking you can easily switch to a new
therapist at any time couldn't be more
sick couldn't be simpler no waiting
rooms no traffic no endless searching
for the right therapist which can be a
pain in the balls by the way learn more
now and save 10 off your first month at
betterhealth.com garbage that's
betterhelp help.com garbage Do It
um all right I have the actual number I
have the actual number of what it cost
off the Met off the menu okay you added
up everything you had added up
everything I had okay my number came in
at 140 dollars
I have uh with that with tax and or with
tax probably 140 I came in at 127. okay
straight off the menu straight off the
menu 127 that all makes sense all right
so 140.
would you leave Kip my keys
in a area your credit card what'd you
leave uh what would you have left
I wrote down a number here this is what
I would have now listen this is what I
would have left sure because
the generosity of doing it a lot of
times as a server when this situation
would happen The [ __ ] who was
friends with and I'm not calling you a
[ __ ] that seems like that's what
you're doing is this about the warm Red
Bull I apologize I said I was sorry uh
wall [ __ ]
who's sitting next to me also my best
friend well you know that that happens
you know my friends are coming in but
but you take real good camera it's on
the arm and they [ __ ] screw you or
they tip you on the discounted price
so but also we didn't really have a
server he kind of just quarterbacked
everything it does I know but I'm just
saying it's not like we had a server and
he was like take care of them but it
okay that's what I'm saying it was we
were at the bar and he was quarterback
and everything but you ate at the bar
yeah he didn't tell me that for sure
mentioned that you ate at the bar that
does change the number I would leave
where's the bartender
he's in his car what do you mean he's at
the bar what were the servers doing
what do you mean it must be a pull that
was a small joint small joint I told you
that all right then yeah then it still
applies okay the number on the inside is
what but I didn't talk to anybody but
him they brought a bartender like do you
need another drink okay like I didn't I
didn't talk to him that's what I'm
saying I didn't have a waiter don't like
the menus were on the [ __ ] scanner he
was just like what do you want I
recommend this this is good this is bad
like he just was that's tough but still
that's what I would have left
and I would have had cash on me too
you're nuts
some have said can I say my number and
see this is not what you would have wait
in what world is that what you leave
that's what I would have left I would
have this is fully doing things it's not
I would have paid for the meal what I
thought the meal was I would have paid
can I tell you what I would have left
150.
whoa Ah that's so crazy now huh I put
eight grand
oh this is bad
rebozo
I really missed that this hard what did
you leave Kevin
I don't want to say holy [ __ ]
that's Foley's number
200. oh [ __ ] that's kind of high that's
50 bucks higher than yours let's not
start splitting here's here we got this
guy on the ropes what are you doing good
point
Dirtbag I love 50 bucks
I'm lying I left 40.
at least a hundred you think yeah man I
really I was I was with that guys for
the guys it was once a cold house it was
a goddamn Wednesday night it was
probably slow that was packed that's why
we're at the bar
do you have a reservation yes were you
supposed to be in a table yes oh well we
got there and it wasn't ready so I was
just like oh the bar is fine interesting
um okay you're still I'm not saying I'm
not uh for sure which I guess I don't
know I guess 40 bucks I I don't know
what I was thinking 40 bucks not cash I
felt I fell as I walked out I'm like
that's not great I I did the math I did
wrong math or something I think I
calculated I'm like all right that would
be 200 bucks and I left the tips 20 of
being a scumbag
hahaha
my okay also too not in my defense by
any means I'm wrong here for sure I I
dropped the ball but I won't tell you
when I left the Gallaghers the other
night at the same time uh I do think
there is a little bit of a slight to
that guy
of like what I'm giving you 200 a slight
to who to the to the manager no not at
all not at all I don't know that I I
he's not well he's not I wouldn't I
wouldn't feel right leaving two hundred
dollars well how do you feel now I feel
fine about it okay I don't think I did
anything wrong
I mean I I left the tip on a 200 Bill
listen I'm not saying it was said I'm
not saying it was discussed
that bald guy at the bar is never
allowed back is that your buddy
um
it could have went a couple different
ways he might not even have saw it
looked at it or asked the servers what
he left
so I've had some owners that didn't give
a [ __ ] about that I've had other owners
that would be like you know what do you
leave you what do you leave you guys the
guy looked at 100 oh it's good that's
good you know he left me 40. glad he
left me a [ __ ] 40. Jesus you believe
that guy I don't really know him friends
with his wife
I'm not talking about you
he lives in my building I don't know
yeah all right I uh I I that's why I
brought it up I I knew I I had
misstepped a bit in that
huh talk about Kinky Boots that is I
don't even tip them either
oh man it's not embarrassing it's not
like you left 20 bucks about it I did
leave 20.
did you really I asked for change what'd
you really leave 40 bucks 40 bucks 40
bucks did you hold on I guess I don't
limit did you make the total forty
dollars or is it at 4109 okay it was
that would have been yikes I don't
whatever at the bar 40 bucks no harm no
foul huh yeah but you're also talking to
two guys who like slugged it out in
horrible restaurants yeah so it's like I
I want that server to be like I'm gonna
make your [ __ ] night a couple of guys
who worked for a living you know what
I'm saying yeah huh a few of those cows
are busy getting high in kitchens I was
working construction idiot I wasn't
getting high in the kitchen I was
getting high out back and I was getting
drunk in the kitchen there we go
drinking cooking wine oh been there
before we're out of Marcelo cooking [ __ ]
out of here we're out of marsala it's
Foley's fault
that stuff will give you a hangover
um
all right let's go we got to get into it
this is a family episode gang as you
know when you join me over the patreon
over there we will answer your garbage
question on the air uh it's just the
best way to do it working through them
Daddio
um let's see here
this one's for Miles uh brand new 10
homie never have on red have you or
anyone in your family ever framed a
puzzle
that's a good piece of business that's a
bad look dude
no my family's ever done a puzzle no I
remember my one family it was a friend
family friend we would go over and they
would do puzzles like as if it would be
on like the dining room table and I'm
like what do you bozos don't have cable
what's happening here you're all [ __ ]
but family matters is on [ __ ] sitting
around doing a puzzle of the [ __ ]
Empire State Building uh we tried to get
my dad to do them it was like a brain
exercise I think like last summer we
were like [ __ ] this he's eating them and
stuff yeah it did it was brutal yeah I
don't know we're just not a puzzle fat
my mom's never been like let's get you a
puzzle Checkers connect fours I remember
3D puzzles got big they were at like
Spencer's Gifts or some hobby shop in
the 90s and like I think we were like oh
that'll be cool like somebody was like
oh cool and it was like a building like
you know like a skyscraper and then like
you know grass in a park or whatever and
I mean it might have gotten like the
sidewalk down and me and my brother were
like [ __ ] this yeah let's go find steal
Dad
we would uh Lincoln Logs we would play
with Lincoln Logs and Legos yeah I mean
of course I'm an American at the end of
the day my dad would hook it up we'd
make a like a little Lincoln Log Fort
and then we'd put a couple of GI Joes in
the windows and then we get some tinfoil
roll up into a ball and go back across
the uh living room and [ __ ] get to
shoot the guys in the windows that's fun
but like a kitty cat hanging off a tree
beat it yeah and then like the proudness
to be like I'm gonna post this [ __ ]
or whatever yeah lacquer it and put it
up I was always jealous of that [ __ ]
though that seems like an intelligent
family that way I know I know because my
these kids that I live next to
um they had like a they had like a like
a it was almost like a den where like
there was no TV in it it was like a
couch there was bookshelves and there
was like like tables specifically for
like crafts and this and that and I had
all that [ __ ] in there construction
paper all that stuff and they would have
like Puzzles out that they were doing
like multiple puzzles like man you guys
are
you guys are good people
we were fighting over the last chicken
cutlet a couple of animals not a lot has
changed apparently uh yeah man that's a
[ __ ] it's a home run of a question I
guess it's like it is I guess it is kind
of intellectual to be like oh we do
puzzles it's brain stimulating it's so
frustrating though but then the framing
of it is the Trashy it's like you're
classy because you're bettering yourself
you're working on your brain you're not
watching TV playing video games but then
it's like you're gonna hang up a puzzle
like that's trash that's not art
now piece is missing out of it and [ __ ]
I mean that was another thing they were
never the dog was eating them [ __ ] it
you know they were kind of everywhere
yeah they would never get framed but my
grandma would do them on a mat and then
glue them to the mat and roll it up
for what move them to the mat and roll
it up for what I don't know man store
them yeah would you do them with them
with her no no no no the original nft
those things my name Mary Kathy just
take me to play bingo with her and the
girls that was a good time I'd do that
all day yeah gambling's way different
than puzzles all right
give me some action a couple old broad
chain smoking cigarettes and I'm the
deep in root beer barrels let's go yeah
uh that was a good time all right this
one's from Devin are you garbage if you
use a leaf blower to get your fire pit
started that's pretty smart got a lot of
likes in the in the old patreon there
which
I guess you need the constant oxygen
like we remember we were at the when we
did the camp and we're sitting there
[ __ ] Fanning it poking it I guess hit
that for 30 seconds a minute or whatever
that'll [ __ ]
it's pretty good that'll get it cooking
fire pits are pretty classy
I think depends yeah sure burning your
trash not really did you have anybody
that burned leaves in your neighborhood
I don't think you were allowed in our
neighborhood no uh-uh not to burn I
don't think you were in ours either but
guy behind us played by his own rules
and I'll tell you what it really brought
in the fall man you would smell the
smell yeah smell those leaves burning on
a Sunday
I remember some real classic pie in the
oven a little married with children on
deck for later that night shout out to
Kelly let's go uh that was her name
right the daughter was Kelly yeah uh I
remember there were some classy
neighborhoods in my area that the
township everybody just pushed their
leaves under the street like only like
and then come and scoop it up they'd
come and [ __ ] suck them up with this
huge vacuum yeah I remember being like
what are you paying taxes [ __ ] crazy
dude for a long time in those [ __ ]
Brown Bags God forbid it rained before
trash day dude [ __ ] so much he's
turned into 78 pounds a clip that was a
weekend in purgatory out there getting
screamed at trying to get him and the
technology was not there yet well it's
like trying to go to the moon in a
[ __ ] convertible it was not there yet
until we be getting yelled at we'd rip
the bag with the metal rake and wait a
day I got the township and get them what
he is doing dude [ __ ] sucks it was
tough I remember we used to do leaf
piles jump out of the tree into the leaf
pile that was a good time yeah scared
the [ __ ] out of the dog that was [ __ ]
great that way you'd be hiding oh yeah
yeah tied in there I know these there's
like the bad kids in the neighborhood
they collected everybody like I don't
know they're walking out with tarps and
filling the tarp up and then dragging it
I used to love that we did that
landscaping and we'll do it like on like
so like dude it would be like something
you would see like a stunt man jump out
of into like one of those big pillows
you know what I mean and they'd be
dropping on like 30 foot trees and [ __ ]
I remember being like nah I'll be on the
deck if you need me right [ __ ] that
home run home run of a question there
yeah
um this is was this is from broja the
Florida man putting an aftermarket
backup camera on your car
that's a bad look I think I think
as a guy who had a 96 Chevy Lumina as my
first car when everybody else had cool
[ __ ] you know where does it even go
do we have a little receiver inside yeah
that's real Chinese Insurance cam yeah
Vibes yeah yeah it's not good just
putting a webcam on a Taurus that's what
you're doing you're putting a webcam
next to your license plate
because that's where it's got to be to
like have any real depth perception and
make sense yeah
yeah it's dude when you try to make your
car cooler than it is it's I mean that's
also for backing up because those things
are great for backing up I know but then
what's the screen looking like that's
not in the dash you know what I mean
that's like plugged into the cigarette
lighter
uh-uh that thing you need double a
batteries for that or something that's
what I'm saying nothing aftermarket
unless you're paying the money right to
be like hey I'm gonna pay five thousand
dollars to have the dash come off custom
fit it the whole thing other if you're
just doing it hit my ride who the [ __ ]
doing that I'm just saying like people
put [ __ ] in their car like well that's
what I'm saying if it's not there where
are you gonna put a TV in a car where
there's not a screen it's gonna look
[ __ ] you got a 42 inch flat screen
it's gonna look like [ __ ] yeah that's
true so it's like the people that do
that don't have the money to do it right
anything after market is garbage for the
most part it depends it depends I mean
if you have a knife's car and put
aftermarket stuff on it that makes sense
what like some Flames
you're doing like performing for Speed
or whatever for comfort you know what I
mean okay no there's different things
you can add I'm sure okay the key are
all stock by the way just in case you're
one they're in stock no add-ons yours
yeah oh there's no options on that now
option for some 12 year old to steal it
with a [ __ ] key fob no we talked
about that I still have the key they
can't steal mine wow it's only the ones
with the remote start analog huh yeah
try to get me daddy yo
he builds an analog cars I hope you got
a screwdriver on your [ __ ] otherwise
she ain't going nowhere yeah let me tell
you about ladder ladder let me tell you
about doing the right thing and making
sure your family's taken care of yeah
some things in life you can kick down
the road a little bit getting a haircut
losing weight whatever you want 200
whatever I don't know whatever you say
but term life insurance is something
that you should look into and something
that you should do to take care of your
family God forbid after you're gone and
latter is a good place to go to do that
yeah guys uh ladder is 100 digital no
doctors no needles no paperwork and you
apply for three million in coverage or
less that's three that's three stacks of
high society that yeah just answer a few
questions about your health and an
application I just need a few minutes a
phone a laptop uh ladder smart
algorithms working real time so you find
out if you're instantly approved and you
choose what you want to do there's no
hidden fees you can cancel any time get
a full refund uh if you change your mind
in the first 30 days look at that
they're playing Fair ball you know what
I mean uh finally since life insurance
costs more as you age now is the time to
cross it off your list so go to
ladderlife.com today to see if you're
instantly approved that's latter I'ma
spell it for you do it
l-a-d-d-e-r life.com slash garbage
ladderlife.com garbage now back to the
show back to the show let's go kept
established titles oh baby let's be
neighbors oh gang we love those
established titles we call it a lord or
lady yourself if you drop a little bit
of cash and pick up some real estate
over there in the Scottish Woodlands
yeah get it on the ground floor let's go
all you gotta do is pick up one square
foot of Scottish woodlands and you
yourself or your lady can be referred to
as duet24 yeah that's how I speak now
it's very real classy guy yeah next time
I go through TSA I'm gonna Flex on be
like that's Lord Kippy to you Kobe cup
of tea let's go guys uh the first 200
people purchasing a title pack using our
link will effectively be next to our
plots within a few minutes of walking
distance some would call that an Empire
let's start the army of garbage boots on
the ground land War Europe what are you
guys talking about you guys know a
blacksmith makes a great last minute
gift for loved ones they even have
couples packs that come into joining
plots of land it's like his and hers
Daddio officially change your name to
Lord or lady and you can use the name on
your credit card plane tickets add some
class to your dating profile there you
go get your little wee-wee wet that
makes an amazing last minute gift The
Savage titles is running a Black Friday
sale plus if you use the code garbage
you'll get an additional 10 off go to
establish titles.com garbage to get your
gifts now and help support the channel
do it yeah
um all right this one's from Peter
schnitzel don't think that's his
government name uh is it garbage if your
buddy is showing you around his new
place with his wife and refers to their
bed as the old workbench
buddy I'm doing that just got stolen if
you don't walk into a couple's bedroom
when they're giving it a tour and saying
that's where it all goes down huh that's
where the magic yeah everybody on MTV
Cribs used to say used to annoy the [ __ ]
out of me yeah [ __ ] get a new writer
do something you know that wasn't even
their houses most of the time
[ __ ] crazy yeah he's on this season
who a friend of ours
I texted her uh uh Whitney Whitney
coming I'm like are you on MTV crib
she's like yeah why are you watching MTV
hey my catfish guy
if he likes a catfish shout out to me I
like the drama yeah oh I do I don't even
like to see
I don't even like the interaction once
they find the person I just like the
pursuit like I love Law and Order I just
love I don't like the found footage look
get some [ __ ] cameras in there will
you it's all them on their cell phone ah
it's good feel bad for the people too
man that's a problem in this I mean it's
everybody thinks I think it's some hot
chicks not me it's I know what catfish
is but this girl loves me and I think
it's something I've been dating for
eight years I've never seen a picture
yeah I show up what's going on yeah
stop get it I get it the internet's a
crazy place
um this is from Tyler first time is it
garbage if your family says kawinky dink
instead of coincidence
my neighbor did that growing up I heard
I remember hearing he goes That's a
clinky dink I was like I'll be having
dinner at my house all right real quick
no we didn't say that yeah it's a tough
one did you say pediddle you know what a
padiddle is that's the guy you stay away
from on your block it's a guy who gets
handsy what are you talking about guys
wants to play doctor with you can you
give him a list hey come over see Dr
padiddle it's time for your weekly
checkup when your parents are going get
molested in Florida no we said padiddle
when a car was coming the other way that
had one headlight you'd say pediddle and
touch the roof of the car
no no we didn't have any weird stuff
like that that's how I'm crazy
I left forty dollars there was a thing
I left 35 dollars
man
hmm that's really gonna bother me it
should
I don't know though should go over there
after the show drop off but the tip
should have been that was the math I did
in my head I'm not saying it was right
math but that was the math I did in my
head you covered the tip at least if it
was a 200 bill it was still a nice day
it wasn't a 200 Bill I'm not saying it
was I did the math in my head I go all
right it's probably but also those
appetizers weren't full appetizers at
the same time they weren't they were off
the menu no but he didn't give us like
full portions I don't think really just
like what do you want I'll bring out
some stuff and it was just like tasting
kind of hmm did you see those appetizers
in those same dishes at any other tables
maybe that's how they do it I didn't
look at any other teams wow they were it
was it didn't feel like I I know an
appetizer will you give me that I was in
the room I know an appetizer you know an
appetizer I was like oh he's these are
just like hey I'll give you he's like
I'll bring some stuff out it was just
like okay okay I left 20 bucks what do
you want 15 bucks padiddle it's a thing
yeah it started in the 1940s as a as a
game
like what 20.
for for kids who were driving around
necking
so if you saw if if you saw a car with a
headband's bluff yeah exactly if you saw
a car with one headlight out you'd say
padiddle and the other person in the car
had to give you a smooch
I know what I'm doing on the next road
trip it did oh boys
Atlanta to Charlotte's going to be
interesting
we'll leave at night um we didn't have
any weird stuff like that the punch
buggy obviously uh that was a thing
holding your breath at a cemetery was
big for like a summer man
to hold your breath because it was like
disrespectful or something I wonder
where you're at no because you would die
that's what we were told I remember
being I remember my mother telling me
that yeah when I was at six try a cup of
decapolis Jesus Christ you [ __ ] this
one up enough that and you had to bless
yourself when you went by your church
otherwise Straight to Hell I used to
take the bus with all the Dominicans all
the Dominican women in the Heights
headed to work in the morning you could
feel what I'd be looking at my phone you
could feel when you passed a church
because everybody on the you could feel
everybody's hands go up and bless
themselves everybody yeah yeah
that's how you do it
um all right let's see here this is from
Nick a long time ten dollar homie never
had one red is a garbage to put the
remaining salad dressing from your bowl
back into the jar to save for later
dude what the [ __ ] hit me up I'll venmo
you five bucks
that's because that's like mixed like
there's cheese in there there's a piece
of lettuce that becomes a different
thing than went in there which can I say
this I know I'm a fat piece of [ __ ] hey
that is my favorite part of the salad
when you get down to that Nitty Gritty
on the bottom and everything's all
chopped up and mixed together
I like a nice relatively dry moist fresh
Leaf at the top really a couple pieces
of chicken yeah I like it all mixed in
that's why the first time I had taco
salad I was blown away that's just the
taco I mean the fact they call that
salad is egregious and I'll never forget
the first time what I had three salads
today first time I had it was a Friday
night eating over my friend's house so
I'm like so what are we having is it
hurts his mom was like I'm making taco
salad I was like taco salad
dude pulled out a [ __ ] heavy bike jar
of [ __ ] Hidden Valley Ranch on the
table [ __ ] ground beef shredded
cheese tomatoes on
wait this might have been a southern
thing but did you boys grow up with
jello salad
no yeah with like like the banana in it
not always some mostly just different
colored jellos yeah oh I've been there
I've seen that that didn't make any we
were Jello no there was something there
was a weird phase with Jello where they
started to do in college
I was drunk it was the 90s they started
making Jello that like
could stand on its own like they would
you you could make
um
like letters out of it or something
that's all I remembered you that was the
marketing campaign for me was the
letters and this like you know there was
like jello Cutters you would like cut
but they like changed the they did
something they changed the formula we
put we'd put bananas in it
there's such a waiting that out was
brutal
I'm gonna wait for dessert until like
[ __ ] 10 o'clock at night [ __ ] what
are we doing here putting two a lot of
times I just went in early
until the instant stuff hit the market
now he never [ __ ] with anything that's
the first time I at the job the
consistency it was Jello letters yeah
Jello letters but they sold them
pre-made I thought
I don't know huh
I don't remember
um all right this one's from Jackson
uh never had one red if the tax man asks
I'm a 500 homie and this is a charitable
organization
shout out to him is it garbage about
popcorn at a movie theater without going
to a movie and then leave and eat it at
home yeah
hear me out I when I first read this I
was like that's kind of trashy but then
like
I think even the city and you're like oh
we're gonna go what if it's movie night
and you live close to like an AMC and
you're like oh this will be a fun
kitschy way to like heighten you gotta
pay for the ticket though right
can you say hey I'm just gonna run and
grab popcorn I'm sure probably yeah you
think so out of some places I don't know
huh uh I can see I can see you know what
I mean like oh let's have like let's
make tonight a little goofy and fun and
we'll you know we'll have wine and we'll
get you dots and or you know snow caps
or whatever we'll make a thing out of it
sure that
that could be cool to me but if you're
just like eating it at home watching
SportsCenter that's a little wonky also
the prices on that what are you doing
call up Orville redenbach oh [ __ ] that's
a dollar clip get the movie popcorn
microwave that put real butter on it bam
it's nice you can get the convenience
stuff delivered now you can get the
popcorn soft pretzels for like movie
Nights probably right yeah I'm like
ubereats yeah they take it from the
movie theater correct yeah I don't trust
that at all why I don't trust those kids
I'm watching every step they make are
you kidding me
yeah you're getting the [ __ ] from the
bottom no I want the fresh stuff I want
to see the kettle get wait you don't you
don't trust the ubereats people or the
the the the kids at the movie theater oh
really you gotta I wanna I don't trust
ubereats oh I don't trust them as far as
I can throw them I don't [ __ ] who breeds
see I'll never order like a fountain
soda because it's just like that guy
could just I just picture him taking his
taking the lid off and putting his
fingers
you don't think I'm not taking a couple
of fries especially if I get held up in
traffic what I just if I've thought of
the way I operate is if I've thought of
it someone's doing it does that make
sense I thought you were gonna say sip
no he doesn't
he gets nothing out of it but just the
fact sure but I'm drinking his finger
juice that's all he gets and as a man
who used to deliver doordash for a
living
yeah dude you got easy access to the
food a couple years ago I got a delivery
and the the drink had the straw in it
I was like nope
I'm not doing that
I didn't like that at all I'll put my
own straw in
I'll put my own fingers in my side and
they never have ice it's they give you
like a lukewarm thing without ice hate
that dude it's crazy give me the ice
because you tape it or she put like a
safety seal so you know it's been
breached we've talked about that a lot
of people [ __ ] they [ __ ] about no
ice they don't wanna not too much ice
because they think they're getting more
oh you farted I did not somebody did no
killing them we have good vibe here
please farted
okay guys I did it all right okay move
on all right
all right you farted you did you did I
smell it I did not
okay okay okay okay okay okay maybe like
five minutes ago
what is it the [ __ ] jet stream it
would have got to you by then
but you did fart while this show has
been on I have farted before yes all
right just immediate lying you can tell
when you what no like a deer on the
headlights when you get called out
foreign
okay
um all right let's see here uh in the
same vein this is uh from luxurious
Lenny
um
we've done this in a live show before
are you garbage are you a garbage parent
or are you garbage if you order
hamburgers at McDonald's and to save the
10 cents you put the cheese on at home
remember we I think I was in Pittsburgh
yeah we had a question like that yeah
yeah yeah uh I mean what yes that's
crazy Jess the the amount of work that
goes into that we gave that we gave that
guy [ __ ] for it too but he wasn't doing
it in the car he brought his own cheese
in the car with him
I forget the application of that yeah I
forget how he did it that is correct he
brought his own cheese and it was Vegas
I believe
Pittsburgh I think that guy didn't know
I was [ __ ] on him and he did not his
wife submitted it and he was like I was
like Steve he's like yeah I was like
okay
I'm gonna whoop my ass yeah
um
that uh
uh that's yeah it's crazy that's what
are you doing 10 saying how many tenses
have you eat where that moves the needle
dude you can save 10 cents somewhere
else is what I'm saying throw your car
in neutral going down a hill or
something and I'm too fat because they
have the bed that their cheese is gonna
be better than any cheese that I have
that McDonald's yellow cheese I don't
know what they put in that [ __ ]
that's something else yeah
I don't know got me thinking though
McDonald's
uh
um all right this one's from Aaron uh
ever get a carton of cigarettes as a
Christmas gift
no
um
growing up a kid did
a friend of mine did and he's no longer
with us if that is it says anything
any smokes left
I have a bag yikes yeah to me that's
that's wild we were under 16. we were
under 18 at the time got it from his
parents Aaron yeah if you want they'd be
like kitchy if you're like oh I got you
I got you a carton of smokes you smoke
the heaters you know what you know why
the parents probably did that I'm sick
of your smoking mine no they didn't even
smell I remember they didn't smoke they
got them cigs and condoms at 16. I was
like dude who were your parents the
Rolling Stones what is this
I live with a guy who ordered cartons of
cigarettes off the dark web yikes paid
for it in Bitcoin which probably would
have been like a bajillion dollars by
now yeah like buying drugs and Bitcoin
back in the day too regular cigarettes
no they were like Cambodian camels dude
remember camels with a K camel red Camel
Reds with a K my brother was smoking him
back in the day were they same company
no it's a different com I feel like I've
talked I've done this with like a
million people that's crazy camels with
a kid that were good you can only buy
them in certain certain uh gas stations
in Philly certain markets they weren't
like knockoffs though they were good
good heaters huh
you said you smoked them uh what's
almost with a K oh I'm familiar oh yeah
yeah
I don't know where they came from or I
don't know what was what but it was like
janky because the logo was similar but
it was also a camel yeah for sure yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah somebody had to buy
somebody out
RJ Reynolds
yeah
there was I mean there is something
where it's like uh you know there's a
breakdown of it somewhere because I've
looked before uh my T-Bone's doing that
let's not do a couple more here
um
this is from rwm are you garbage if you
prefer booths over tables at a
restaurant how does the bar factor in
this is very in our wheelhouse this is
very in our wheelhouse
um most boost I can't fit in yeah but uh
we were always table people really yeah
we were always a booth a boost even get
a booth man maybe we were we were all we
were a big Booth family if there was a
smoking Booth we're gonna get the corner
Booth oh that's clean living so I feel
like a [ __ ] good fellow what are you
talking about we were also a huge uh
like me and my if it was the smoking
section people
uh I believe in a time yeah I remember
having like hop in run into like [ __ ]
Gyros or whatever and be like hey
yeah how long does it wait for for
smoking
and then I've run back out and be like
hey we'll see this right away
crazy man just ripping a heater at the
table multiple Heats
let's play with the ashtray I know
hey what the [ __ ] was wrong I solved a
crossword puzzle in two minutes give me
a smoke what do you got T-Bone it's made
by the same company it's made by RJ
Reynolds who owns Camel cigarette like
real Camel cigarettes yeah they they
shelved it after us for 60 years in 1936
and then brought it back in the mid 90s
uh but that's insane that would be like
if Coke released coke with the cake it's
all money yeah but it's also just they
don't give a [ __ ] brand deviation it's
like ah they'll try these These are
Quasar kitschy it's different I smoke
camels with a K we're talking about
giving them free press yeah we're
smoking things not to check Reynolds
consuming things that kill you what do
you mean they think we're idiots
got a spot of balls you ain't lying um
the smoking section thing I go I think
to me I think boots
are better I don't know if they're
classy or necessarily I feel a table
would be clear I just only people behind
me I think a booth would be the more
sought out of of the of the two booths
are a table yeah both they got a little
cubby you got your stuff over here you
never really hear a table if you have it
you hear a boo Booth if you have it yeah
they're more cozy better environment
better it creates a better you're in
your own little Hub over there any of
you can get got if you're in the middle
of the restaurant at a wide open table
if you were in there with just your dad
or your uncle or you and your brother or
something like that if there was no
birds at the going to the counter was
all right tell me you feel like a man I
don't know if we were ever really
huge I mean when I was if I was with my
dad and he was we were drinking he was
drinking I was at the bar for sure like
give him a Coke yeah Coke and the
[ __ ] your finest chicken fingers and
french fries shut him up for a bit rip
it up Zing give me [ __ ] 10 bucks to
play go play Golden tea or something I
can't take a walk fatty uh go play
erotic photo hunt
that was all right that wasn't too
shabby yeah spin around get your little
privacy
over in the corner uh all right let's do
one more and then we got a wrapper up
there let's do two more two more I
apologize uh this is from Cole Shaw or
kale show I can't tell uh 10 investor do
you open stuff with your teeth yes
yes I do yeah yeah yes I do I'm not like
crazy I don't open [ __ ] beer bottle
but are you stupid
[ __ ] Coors Light can't I I would do
that to open the can what yeah no I'm
talking about your finger under there
now I'm talking about like a bag or like
uh like an alcohol wipe or something
like that and you give it a little twist
that's a good time yeah one of those
titles now they're perforated edges or
edges are a little better but so yeah
sometimes they don't yeah now they back
in the day they would miss the cut that
wouldn't be there so you really had to
[ __ ] her get it going yeah that's a lot
of stuff you could pick your teeth with
that too once you get that tuck uh-huh
Good Times uh this is from ten dollar
Hoagie shout out
that's a home run ten dollars uh this is
is it garbage to eat your chips and
salsa straight from the jar instead of
pouring the poured into a bowl like a
gentleman it is now is it here's my
thing on that I feel like it changes can
you put it in a bowl you have it's not
it's not as good yes exactly but I don't
know why if we're talking restaurant
style chips that could Jam me up with
trying to get it in there now you gotta
you gotta crack it then it gets wonky
usually Scoops are all right or the
little [ __ ] silver dollar Jones those
are my favorite a little Scoops but the
[ __ ] little little Sacagawea coins oh
man those things are bangers all day
long perfect surface here at a rigid
hold nine here's the thing what's the
thing
you got till it's halfway empty yeah
then you're doing this you're doing this
deal yeah fresh jar nothing better fresh
sugar fresh jar it until it's a half a
jar then you put it in a bowl but then
it's all done too you're like I'm
finishing this
unless it's a salsa con queso you put
that in a bowl throw it in a microwave
15 seconds come out
little place called heaven
South of the Border baby let's go
talking to me we gotta wrap her up gang
gang we love you to death thank you so
much uh we got anything to report might
be a couple tickets left for the shows
check out the live shows uh we're
wrapping it up here they're wrapping it
up or coming down wrapping up uh
Providence in Boston Providence in
Boston uh yeah guys we [ __ ] love you
thanks for the support uh see you next
time peace peace